myasthenia gravis is a chronic
autoimmune disorder which cause
weakening and fatigue in the muscle in
myasthenia gravis there are Auto
antibodies which attack the synaptic
acetylcholine receptors which lead to
disruption of the communication between
nerve and the muscle
so this is a cholinergic synapse where
acetylcholine is released in the
synaptic cliff and acetylcholine
receptor is activated by acetylcholine
which allows the cation flux and thereby
muscle contraction since the
acetylcholine receptors are heavily
blocked by the auto antibodies it
disrupts the nerve and muscle connection
so this is how it is disrupted in the
myasthenia gravis patient there are
little bit amount of cation influx in
the muscle that reduce the chance of
muscle contraction
this leads to obviously muscle weakness
this can be detected in electromyography
or by detecting the acetylcholine
receptor antibody in the serum
watch the full video to do more